pourquoi
[Musique]
bonjour marc loos et sa carte à autre et
je vous en prie droite
c'est c'est une maison magnifique
[Musique]
vous serez salle ici ou
pardon à la marne ou non non un tiers
payant leurs
notre mandat
une pomme du jardin oui elle était
délicieuse non maintenant il faut pas
faire ça c'est un fruit défendu ah je
suis désolé je savais je plaisante
[Musique]
vous êtes tourmenté non c'est plus comme
si j'étais
hanté ouais
il s'est produit quelque chose mon mari
est monté sur notre balcon
et se laisser tomber
vous devez vous demander pourquoi vous
l'y avait poussé
pourquoi je suis pas responsable
peut-être pas
mais si vous lui aviez accordé une
chance de se faire pardonner
il serait toujours en vie
un homme
m'a suivi à la sortie des bois
il me suivait qu'est ce qui vous fait
dire ça je t'ai vu deux fois deux fois
mais je sais pas si lui vous avez eu une
fois
[Musique]
bonjour un jeu vous vous cacher je
cherche
vous devez vous sentir apte en semant
potable
si vous approchez pas de moi
vous êtes quoi
[Musique]